trouver quelqu'un pour me sentais la
salle décrire champions en formation il
faut être hors norme pour consacrer
toute sa vie et toutes ses énergies à
prendre soin des autres
c'est le cas de bruno et malik douze
hommes qui portent à bout de bras des
associations qui prennent soin de
personnes autistes tout en embauchant
des jeunes de quartiers difficiles
j'ai l'impression que hors norme est
l'aboutissement de quelque chose qu'on a
envie de dire tout au long de mes autres
films
les concentrés dans vos films aient
envie de parler des gens vulnérables
jeunes en me parler de cas complexes des
gens qui s'occupent d'autres gens et
qu'ils donnent leur vie pour s'occuper
d'audience les réalisateurs olivier
nakache et eric toledano à qui on doit
les succès on touche à bhl nos jours
heureux et le sens de la fête se sont
inspirés de véritable association et de
vrais anges gardiens on va les voir
souvent
et à chaque fois qu'on va les voir on ne
perde être épatés par eux alors qu'on
les connaît depuis 25 ans en passant par
quelle station salazar aux côtés de
vincent cassel et reda kateb des acteurs
autistes non professionnels étaient
capitales on parle de gens qui me fait
de vouloir inclure un des gens oublient
différents l'équipe a et c'est pourquoi
j'ai dû film donc a juste pris un peu
plus de temps l'humoriste mathieu
gratton et le père de benjamin aux
jeunes autistes et le fondateur du monde
2 benjamins un site qui vise à
sensibiliser la population à la cause de
l'autisme
un film comme se donne le goût de
s'impliquer donc cesser ces suspects une
comédie là c'est pas non plus un film
d'action mais c'est un film qui fait du
bien parce que quand on a fini de
l'écouter on se dit pas inquiet qu'est
ce qui pourrait faire de plus pour aider
mais mon prochaine il s'est reconnu dans
la réalité présentée par hors norme
moi ça m'a vraiment rappeler
ma vie à moi avec mon fils parce que les
enjeux c'est l'intégration son marché du
travail
encore là c'est pas un documentaire mais
on voit comment j'ai avec les personnes
autistes après on se rend compte un
moment donné que l'agressivité
l'impatience sont totalement
incompatibles avec ces personnes lui
hors norme et une ode à la différence et
à la générosité et ciney bien alexandre
charti radio canada montréal